shopping malls may just seem like
clusters of stores but they're actually
very delicate profit-making formulas the
ideal place to settle a mall is a
central wealthy location with lots of
traffic close enough to attract locals
easily driven to from nearby towns and
for maximum profit tourists accessible
with everything planned just right a
mall is far more fruitful than its
individual stores could ever be but even
then the tides seem to be turning how
can even the perfect mall beat the price
and convenience of Amazon and the data
seems to confirm online shopping is on
the rise while more and more malls are
withering away but graphs like this are
misleading the mall is far from dying
and Amazon only confirms this before we
get there we first need to understand
what makes a mall unique because malls
are owned and managed by a single
company their incentives are very
different from an individual store a
group of small local stores is normally
the perfect opportunity for a big
corporation to come in and steal their
business but to the owner of a mall too
much competition means fewer stores and
less rent being made so they carefully
pick renters that not only cooperate but
actually complement one another this is
why malls tend to have a similar set of
stores whether you're in Washington or
Wyoming well if there are malls in
Wyoming each class of mall from the
5-star to the less than glamorous has a
standard meta deck of stores that have
been proven to generate more profit
together regardless of where it's
located
but the real heart of the mall are the
anchor stores big department stores that
draw in the crowds for everyone else
you'd never drive to a store
specifically for remote-controlled
helicopters or seasonal moustache
warmers but if one anchor store can lure
you into the mall these other shops get
your business - and they're positioned
on opposite ends of the building making
you walk past everything else to get
between them the goal of a drive-thru is
to get you in and out as quickly as
possible but malls are just the opposite
doing anything and everything to prolong
your stay they want to satisfy your
needs so well that it's always just
easier to stay a little bit longer so
for every need on Maslow's hierarchy
there's a convenient solution not
steps away the foodcourt fills you up
brave deputies stand guard friends keep
you company
and your purchases are psychologically
rewarded companies even seem to think
they're providing some sort of profound
civic duty
actually don't call them stores anymore
we call them town squares but there's an
obvious problem with this strategy more
and more people can't or don't want to
spend a lot of time shopping it may take
some time but the trend seems clear
physical retail stores are dying and the
internet will be the new way to shop
there's one big problem with this theory
Amazon just bought the grocery store
Whole Foods for 14 billion dollars if
physical retail stores are soon to be a
thing of the past
wire companies like Amazon and Alibaba
investing in them part of these deals is
about getting data for the algorithms
but nowhere near 14 billion dollars
worth but if you take a closer look at
which stores are closing you may notice
a theme these are businesses that never
adapted they cross their fingers that
this internet thing would be a fad and
kept selling the exact products Amazon
is great for unless I need an HDMI cable
this very instant I'm just going to buy
one online and probably even save some
money but the average shopper at Whole
Foods has a thousand dollars of
discretionary income to spend a month
they want to pay for a premium
experience
likewise everything in an Apple store
could be sold online but they continue
building newer shinier stores at great
expense Amazon sees this pattern to walk
in stores aren't dying old outdated ones
are so what does this mean for malls
the bad news is that many of these dying
businesses are actually anchor stores
for average middle-class malls without a
Macy's or JCPenney paying rent and
attracting visitors many are in serious
trouble
but higher-end malls are doing better
than ever the more expensive the store
the more customers care about the
experience and the harder it is for the
internet to replace as long as the upper
class keeps growing upscale malls will
only do better and better so yes there
are malls that are dying but malls as a
thing aren't dying at all and neither is
retail the best way to predict the
future is to look at where big smart
companies are putting their money and
companies like Amazon and Apple are
clearly betting on walk and retail being
around for a long time so you should too
you can shop this holiday season knowing
the mall Santa will be back next year
and with luck we may even be blessed
with paul Blart 3 this video is
sponsored by Skillshare Skillshare is a
website and mobile app with full high
quality video courses on all sorts of
topics both fun and professional let me
actually recommend two course topics
first the Adobe apps I've wanted to
learn After Effects for some time but
the interface is just so needlessly
complicated it's the same with Photoshop
Illustrator and all the others
everything about these programs seems
designed to confuse you so it's really
ideal to have someone explain them for
you when I've gotten errors or had
something weird happen with an
application I'm learning I've asked a
Skillshare instructor and quickly gotten
it answered another cool course I found
is on calligraphy my penmanship is
terrible and it's also just a fun skill
to learn it took me about 30 seconds to
find a good course for beginners and you
can take them at whatever pace works for
you the first 300 people to use this
link will get two months to see if you
like it for free it really helps support
this channel and if none of the 17,000
classes interest you you can leave at
any time without paying a cent thanks
again to Skillshare